you'll probably recall through the
course of this pandemic we've been
looking at this screen
at the data about covert 19 and a lot of
it has been very depressing
indeed well i have some good news which
is that a lot of these charts we're
about to show you the higher the lines
are
the better the news is because we're
looking at vaccinations the progress of
vaccinations and also whether it's
actually starting
to have an effect of course a lot of
focus in the uk really
recently has been on this line getting
to kind of 15 million first dose
vaccinations by the 15th of february
well did we get there we'll have a look
at the line this shows you cumulative
first days vaccinations and yes it got
above 15 million
uh on the 14th of february so 15.1
million and expected to continue
climbing in the coming weeks let's
compare the uk with other countries
around the world there's been a lot of
talk of comparisons about the uk being
much further ahead well
it certainly is on one measure okay so
just take that line now we're looking at
per hundred of the population so we can
actually just compare it across
countries i'll come over here so you can
see
and i'm going to add on europe uh
various countries in europe so you can
see
just the big difference between where
the uk is and the rest of europe this is
total vaccinations
and you can see spain italy germany
france and the netherlands just just
look at that gap it really is striking
where they are versus the uk and then
add on a few other countries for
instance the u.s
somewhere in the middle in terms of
total vaccinations more than any other
country
but obviously per head of the population
and somewhere between those two groups
there
and then other countries from chile big
rise uh in chile in terms of
vaccinations there
i should say though this is countries
with uh populations below 10 million
sorry above 10 million if we include
countries that have populations that are
slightly below there we'll just have a
look at this okay
have a look at where israel and the uae
are look at those charts it's really
striking isn't it you can see just
israel
way ahead of almost anyone else and then
if you've got the united
arab emirates just below it there uh as
well i should say though these these are
total vaccinations and a lot of people
have been wondering you know whether
you've got first doses you've got some
countries which are insisting on going
for kind of two doses
as quickly as possible the uk delaying
that second dose so how do the how does
it look
if we look at fully vaccinated people so
people who have had
two doses of those relevant vaccinations
it is actually a very different picture
so have a look at this
this is again uh per hundred the
population you've got israel
way ahead of anyone else there the
higher this is more people
have been fully vaccinated then you've
got the u.s then spain then italy so
actually these european countries um
have vaccinated more people
fully than the uk that's not often
appreciated that the uk although it's
kind of
it's really gone for that first dose
thing and a lot of the medical evidence
from the who
uh to others suggests that is a a
sensible thing to do
uh in the circumstances the uk uh
actually behind most other
developed countries when it comes to
fully vaccinated uh
people um the real question though and i
know that you know everyone has been
focusing on this
a lot of people trying to look at the
data to work out what uh the impact is
going to be
uh is just trying to get that sense so
in israel you know there it does seem to
be some evidence
that now that vaccination program is
bearing down uh on deaths
how about in the uk obviously uh moving
slightly slower than israel
have we seen an impact when it comes to
the change in deaths
this is the kind of back of an envelope
effort i'm gonna show you something
slightly more scientific in a moment
but what we can do is just look at the
change
uh in death since the peak that happened
uh obviously
uh we've got two peaks here we've got
the first peak the first wave peak
and that's how fast deaths came down
back in the spring
and the the interesting exercise is to
compare the shape of what we're going
through now at the moment
is the curve going to come down quicker
or slower than last time around if it
comes down quicker it might be a sign
there are lots of other things going on
as well i should say
but it might be a sign that that
vaccination program is having
an impact and here's what we see so
coming down at more or less the same
speed
but it does seem to have accelerated in
the last week or so
so if that continues to accelerate maybe
that's a sign
that the vaccination program might be
bowing down on this but like i say
really a more scientific way of looking
at this is to look at
age groups in particular and one way of
doing that is looking at case fatality
rates now the case brutality rate is the
percentage of people who die for any
given case and you can kind of break it
down by age groups so clearly
those who are younger so you've got 50
uh to 60 and so on
those who are younger are less likely to
die of this virus whereas you can see
the older age groups you've got much
higher levels so back
in the kind of early point of january so
when there was at their maximum in this
wave
you can see that you're kind of getting
almost towards 50 percent case fatality
rates
in those uh age between 90 and kind of
120 so 90 max
what we can do and this is a really i
think a really interesting exercise
that's been carried out by the center
for evidence-based medicine
at oxford what we can do is specifically
look at those
older age groups who have mostly got the
vaccination now so 80 plus that
highlighted them there and just have a
look and see whether they have changed
from that point max in january uh early
january
to where we are now this is where we are
now it's pretty striking isn't i'm going
to show you that one more time we'll
just go back so
early january and look at that just look
in particular at those 80 plus
uh age groups there and compare them
with the other age groups everyone's
down a bit
but just look how much further those 80
plus age groups have come in comparison
uh with everyone else uh another way let
me show you another way of kind of
looking at this just two simple bars
just to
make that point and here we're just
looking at the change in the case
fatality rate
uh since that maximum point so the
further down it is
the better news that is because that's
fewer people dying and you can see
under 80s case fatality rate down by
five percent
over 80s down by 35
so this is tentative news but it is good
news it suggests that there is
an outsize impact on case fatality rates
recently
which is very it's it's probable
no one knows for sure but it's for
probable or plausible that that could be
down to the vaccinations uh and i'll
just show you one other way of looking
at
uh which is to look just at a chart and
say this is the point where vaccinations
began
you've got under 80s and over 80s so
underrated is that black line
and they were more or less correlated
they're on different scales at the
moment obviously because you're
much less likely to die uh if you are
younger and get the disease but it's the
shape of these that we're looking at
and the key thing is the way that they
have diverged in the last
few weeks and that divergence has
continued to the extent that
the gap between them is bigger than it's
ever been so the gap potentially and you
you know your likelihood of dying as a
result of this disease
when you're over 80 versus when you're
under 80. that's diverged more than ever
before so this is
really promising news but of course you
know we have to wait and see what this
data shows us
in the next few weeks there's a few
other things that i want to just kind of
talk about finally we're still
we don't have all the data we would
really like i talked a bit earlier
about how we've kind of got beyond that
15 million point well let's not forget
the government was talking not about 15
15 million vaccinations administered but
15 million vaccinations
offered to those in those categories who
most needed them
what we don't have is detailed data
about how many vaccines have actually
been offered so we don't know how many
have been offered in total
it's more than that clearly but we don't
know how mad it'll be nice to know about
that it'd be nice too
to know about which vaccinations have
been given so you know you'll be kind of
well aware that we have various
different types of vaccines that have
been ordered by the uk government so
you've got all the way from modern 17
million of those
those jansen pfizer biontech that first
one 40 million of those
and then other vaccines which haven't
not yet been approved all the way
through to this
oxford astrazeneca the majority of them
we know how many have been ordered and
there you can see those numbers
what we don't know is who is getting
them and it would be useful to know that
and we don't you know
some we get some of that data from
scotland we don't have all of that for
the uk so
there's still some big gaps when it
comes to what we know about this uh
vaccination program in terms of the data
but broadly speaking
as i say there's been so much bad news
we've had to show you on this screen
it's nice to show you some good news
and hopefully those trends will continue
we'll bring you up to date with them
as those lines come come out as we get
more data on the case brutality rates
and as we find out whether this
vaccination program is indeed starting
to work